Every town has its urban legends.
An unnatural abomination with the body of
an animal and the head of a human lurking
the forests.
A bridge said to curse any who stand under
it in the dead of night.
A lurking serial killer continuing his crimes
from beyond the grave.
You might be familiar with the hook-man, a
chilling tale about a young couple finding
a man’s hooked-hand hanging on the back
of their car.
Or tales about mysterious clowns being sighted
in the woods outside of suburban areas.
Over time, the truth behind an urban legend
will become muddled, and the original story
might change countless times before emerging
in its present form.
They might entertain us, they sometimes might
even scare us, but all urban legends feed
on the tiny sliver that they might be true.
That voice inside your head telling you that
it might not be just a story designed to scare
you, and that there are some aspects of the
world that are truly unknown.
And most of all, you, the average person,
can get caught up in this world, forced into
it against your will by pure chance.
A deranged killer, an unknown sea creature
lurking in a lake, a curse, a poorly understood
creature never before seen by science.
All of these images conjure up fear, but when
combined with the personalized nature of an
urban legend, which adds familiar places,
names, and situations to the mix, it’s no
wonder why these stories take off.
Rodney Hallow’s town, the name of which
has been scrubbed from all documentation by
the Foundation, was no different in that it
had its own share of urban legends.
Even though the town’s name is lost due
to the SCP Foundation wiping its name from
official documentation, know that Rodney was
an average teenager, living an average life,
and doing average things a person his age
might do.
And that included taking his friends up on
dares that he might regret later, dares pertaining
to those urban legends.
Kids daring one another to do something like
this is nothing new.
Whether it’s saying ‘bloody mary’ 3
times in a row before a bathroom mirror in
the dark, or taking a trip to an abandoned
building and staying the night there, you
should be undoubtedly familiar with how these
things work, and how easy it is to get a susceptible
young mind to do them.
Who wants to risk an encounter with the supernatural?
Well, people who don’t want to chicken out
in front of their friends, of course!
Getting cursed by a ghost or the more realistic
possibility of accidentally injuring yourself
while exploring an abandoned area is nothing
compared to the feeling of satisfaction that
comes from looking cool in front of your friends,
at least, that rings true when you’re 14
years old.
But Rodney Hallow was above that.
He was, more than anything else, a scaredy
cat to his core.
No amount of peer pressure could make him
fold, because his fears outweighed his social
capital.
If Rodney was afraid of it, his friends knew
there was no chance of getting him near it.
In a way, it was admirable.
He could be offered money, food, literally
anything he wanted, and if Rodney didn’t
want to do it, he wouldn’t.
Not just that, but he felt like he physically
couldn’t.
It was like every bone in his body would freeze
up, his heart would start beating intensely,
and he would internally panic.
It was a regular feeling of fear, sure, but
Rodney felt it often.
A fear of exams, a fear of the future, snakes,
spiders, open windows at night.
Rodney was always overthinking things, and
his fears were well known among the small
circle he associated himself with.
Naturally, Rodney’s friends acted their
age, and spent a lot of time trying to come
up with new and exciting ways to scare the
daylights out of the poor kid.
This could be playing pranks on him, giving
Rodney phone calls from hidden numbers, or
trying to get him to watch horror movies.
It was getting to the point where Rodney was
more annoyed than anything else, and he was
beginning to heavily reconsider who he hung
out with.
But if there was one person who could convince
Rodney to do something, it was Clair, a girl
in his class he had a tiny bit of a crush
on.
And by a tiny bit, we mean that Rodney was
so willing to make himself look good in front
of Clair that he willingly accompanied his
friends to a supposedly haunted house located
in a rural area just outside of town.
This was Rodney’s town’s urban legend,
and while it wasn’t well-known, this broken-down
house was slowly gaining a reputation among
the town’s youth as a gateway between the
realm of the living and the dead.
The lore varied depending on who you asked,
but it was said to be haunted by the spirit
of a puppet-maker, who was experimenting with
making puppets out of human bodies.
His reclusive nature and isolated lifestyle
meant that his crimes and experiments went
unnoticed until his death, when law enforcement
seized the house and cleared out hundreds
of mutilated, half-human, half-wooden puppet
creations.
Of course, this was all just hearsay, and
there was no actual proof beyond what was
said at Rodney’s lunchtable.
But as seasoned viewers of this channel know,
in the world of the SCP Foundation, there
is always a kernel of truth in even the slightest
story of the unknown.
The outline of Rodney’s dare was simple.
He and Clair would have to spend an hour inside
the house alone, while his friends waited
for him outside of it.
Pretty great friends, huh?
Under any other circumstances, Rodney would
have refused to even leave his house that
night, but the prospects of looking good in
front of Clair were too tempting for even
the scardiest of scaredy-cats to pass up.
Besides, if he played it cool, he could use
this as a way to talk to Clair and actually
get to know her a bit better.
They’d have a whole hour together!
Just… an hour inside a dark, dilapidated
house occupied by a puppet-maker serial killer’s
ghost.
Still, Rodney clenched his fist and grit his
teeth, determined to shake off his reputation
as a wimp.
The house stood before him, and Clair stood
beside him.
They moved forward together, much to the chuckling
and stifled laughter of the kids behind them,
and with a forceful jiggling of the locked
doorknob using a makeshift lockpick made of
a paperclip and a piece of metal, they entered
the house.
The inside was dark, but that much was to
be expected.
As soon as the two entered, the door slammed
itself shut, and a clicking sound was heard,
indicating that it was now locked.
Immediately, Rodney knew something was wrong.
He had a feeling he would see some unexplainable
things, but he didn’t expect one to occur
immediately after he entered.
The door just slammed itself shut.
Clair turned back and attempted to open it,
but she had no luck.
Rodney, in what he felt was a smooth move,
told her to calm down, and that when their
hour was eventually up, they could just break
through a window to get out.
This seemed to work, and Clair hesitantly
calmed herself.
The interior of the house was old, done in
a baroque style unfitting of the unimpressive
exterior.
A spiraling staircase, a few paintings, armchairs
in front of a fireplace.
It was clear that whoever lived here, if they
didn’t have money, they certainly had access
to skilled craftsmanship.
There were faint pockets of light in the distance,
coming from candles positioned sparsely throughout
the home.
The two began to explore, not content to stay
in any one place for too long.
The frightened duo came to an ornate, yet
run-down kitchen.
Their footsteps creaked with every movement,
but when they stopped, they noticed that the
stepping sounds didn’t.
Rodney began to panic, as he was used to.
Keeping a cool head in this situation was
next to impossible.
Slow stepping sounds, coming from various
parts of the house.
They moved closer, practically clinging to
each other.
If Rodney wasn’t so scared, this would have
been an ideal situation, but he couldn’t
even appreciate it.
The footsteps didn’t grow louder, they just
increased in number.
Slow, moving steps coming from above, below,
and beside them.
And then, in the distance, from the poorly-lit
hallway in front of them, Rodney saw a shape.
A jerkily-moving, barely-visible shape, but
it was approaching them.
Clair saw it too, and the two ran out of the
kitchen and back to the front of the house.
They banged on the door, begging and screaming
for their friends to let them back out, but
there was no response.
They tried to break open a window, but they
physically found themselves unable to damage
the house.
It was as if they wanted to protect it instead
of damage it, even though both of them knew
they absolutely wanted to break a window and
run out of the house as fast as possible.
The figure was approaching, and the footsteps
didn’t stop either.
It was then that Rodney caught a glimpse of
the figure that was trailing them, a picture
only visible due to the brief flash of candle-light.
It was a sunken, hollowed out corpse, with
button-eyes and rust-brown skin.
As soon as it moved beyond the candle, the
entity was difficult to see again, but Rodney
was unable to scrub that brief image from
his mind.
It jerked towards them, slow step by slow
step.
And then, it lunged forward at a frighteningly
fast, unnatural speed.
The two screamed.
Rodney fell to the floor, passed out in fear.
And then everything went quiet.
Rodney and Clair were just another disappearance
that had a connection to that abandoned house,
and when the local police force launched an
investigation, they compiled over 20 cases
of teenagers from ages 12 to 17 that went
missing as a result of visiting the abandoned
home over the past decade.
A small team of law enforcement was dispatched
to inspect and investigate the home in-person,
but they did not return.
It was at this point when the incident caught
the attention of the SCP Foundation, who overtook
the investigation and launched a massive cover
story that involved a mass amnesticization
of law enforcement officers and relatives
of the missing persons, as well as a planting
of a memetic agent in the area that induced
brain patterns that would discourage the town’s
residents from talking about or spreading
the urban legend of the house.
The Foundation quickly established containment
procedures and a security perimeter was set
up around the house.
After a cursory, preliminary batch of research
and testing, the house was decidedly anomalous,
and was given the designation of SCP-1098-RU,
labeled as such due to the investigation taking
place in Russia and being handled by the Russian
branch of the SCP Foundation.
SCP-1098-RU’s containment procedures, on
top of the cover story that was put into place
to discourage and suppress the spread of the
urban legend, were effective in deterring
civilians from entering the area.
Originally, the city administration had proposed
to destroy and dismantle the house years ago,
but the building’s demolition was constantly
postponed by bureaucratic red tape.
The entirety of the area was fenced in, and
patrolled by an armed security detail at all
hours, with the guards shifting positions
every six hours.
If any civilians attempted to enter, they
would be arrested and interrogated, with the
use of amnestics permitted.
If anything regarding SCP-1098-RU were to
change, the guards would have to report it
to Site-7 and wait for further instruction.
From the Foundation’s research, it was determined
that SCP-1098-RU was a difficult anomaly to
analyze.
The house’s primary anomalous effect was
a protective one.
All of the windows and the front door of SCP-1098-RU
were automatically locked, and if someone
attempted to enter the house via physically
damaging one of these spots, or anywhere else
on the house, they would find themselves unable
to do so.
Instead, they would feel motivated to protect
SCP-1098-RU, and prevent any damage to it.
This, of course, wouldn’t override any other
preexisting feelings toward the house, so
as we saw in Rodney’s case, this can result
in a conflict of interest where a victim wanted
to escape, but was unable to due to the house’s
protective trap.
This effect is only active when a person is
within at least 50 meters of SCP-1098-RU,
which explains why the plans for the house’s
demolition were plotted, but actually unable
to be carried out.
The only way to enter SCP-1098 is the house’s
front door, through use of a lockpicking device
or another way to break the door’s lock.
Upon entry, the door will close automatically,
lock itself from the outside, and is unable
to be opened for the next hour.
Attempts to break into the house before this
hour is through are futile, as the anomaly’s
protective measures will trigger in order
to prevent damage coming from the house.
The home’s origins are presently unknown,
as the Foundation is still investigating them,
but the urban legend of the puppet-maker who
turned his victims into puppets may hold some
credence.
SCP-1098-1 is an entity that has been nicknamed
the Master of Puppets, and you’re about
to see why.
But the entity is a self-containing spirit,
believed to be the cause of most of the anomalous
phenomena within the house.
The Foundation hasn’t found a way to contact
or research the -1 entity beyond observing
the brief appearances of it during testing,
so information on the anomaly is limited to
what’s been observed.
And that would be candles that are unable
to be extinguished or replaced, strange glows
of light emerging from the cracks in sealed
windows and walls, hallucinations based on
the fears of the victims trapped inside, and
the sound of slow, approaching steps from
throughout the house.
These steps are unable to be recorded using
audio devices, but the Foundation has reason
to believe they’re produced by the entity
itself.
Still, there’s a lot of mystery surrounding
SCP-1098.
Where did it come from?
What is the SCP-1098-1 entity?
And most importantly, where do the corpses
of its victims go?
That one is easy to answer.
The bodies of those who die inside SCP-1098
will be preserved by the entity, and altered
to take on the appearance of puppets.
Their eyes will be removed and long, thick
threads will be sewn into their extremities.
But what does SCP-1098-RU need these puppets
for?
A look into the Foundation’s initial research
documents regarding the house may provide
the answer.
The Foundation’s exploration of SCP-1098-RU
occurred shortly after the object was put
into containment, and remains the primary
source of information on how the anomaly functions
and how its intricacies work.
The first test involved a remote controlled
drone equipped with recording equipment, the
Foundation’s safest way to observe hostile,
unknown anomalous territory from a distance.
The drone entered, and was quickly locked
inside the house.
As it proceeded, it found several damaged,
altered corpses of missing persons in various
rooms of the house.
The bodies were missing their eyes, and all
had thick strings sewn onto them, with stitch
marks on the chest and face areas.
Strangely, the bodies weren’t decomposed
at all, despite some of the corpses being
identified as being people who disappeared
months ago.
The drone’s survey also found several objects
of interest.
A set of surgical knives, threads, needles,
and a prosthetic, artificial eye.
While the drone didn’t detect the -1 entity,
Foundation researchers could only speculate
as to where and what these objects were used
for, and by who.
The second test involved sending a D-Class
personnel into the building.
He was supplied with a flashlight and recording
equipment, and was tasked with reexamining
the first floor of the house.
The only difference the D-Class observed from
the drone exploration was that the candles
were clearly replaced by newer ones, indicating
that someone had changed them.
Footsteps were heard throughout the home,
sometimes in areas that the D-Class had just
emerged from.
Upon re-entering one room to investigate,
the D-Class was ordered to take a surgical
knife back to command for further study.
However, as soon as he lifted the knife, communication
immediately cut off, and the Foundation was
unable to re-establish contact.
A third test was held shortly after to determine
what happened to the D-Class, as well as explore
the second floor of SCP-1098, this time using
another remote controlled drone.
The drone found that the house, on its second
floor, had a sewing workshop, filled with
all of the materials you would expect to find
in such, including threads, machinery, and
tools.
Multiple corpses were found, all dressed in
18th century clothes, their eyes replaced
with artificial ones, and with strings sewn
into their bodies.
Upon the drone’s return, communication was
cut off yet again, and when the hour period
was up and the house’s door opened, there
was no sign of it anywhere.
The fourth test into SCP-1098 involved another
D-Class personnel, who was instructed to attempt
to leave the building before an hour passed.
After entering, the D-Class reported a throbbing
headache and immediate pressure in his ears.
He reported that someone was crying in the
farthest room on the first floor, but the
equipment couldn’t pick anything up.
After entering, he reported that he saw a
little girl, wearing an old-fashioned dress,
and she was dancing and crying, being pulled
upward into motion by the strings that were
sewn onto her back.
These strings, on camera, were completely
invisible to the Foundation, leading the command
to believe that the D-Class was experiencing
hallucinations.
The D-Class simply stood and observed, almost
transfixed by the girl.
He remarked that it seemed like the strings
stretched on forever, and that there was no
ceiling, even though the Foundation could
clearly see the ceiling of the room on the
camera.
After 5 minutes of silence and observation,
a startling clap was heard as the camera’s
visuals cut out.
And then, a male voice, but not that of the
D-Class, spoke:
“In perficientur est pretium.”
When translated from latin to english, it
read: “The performance must be paid for”.
After this, the Foundation put a stop to all
further experimentation with SCP-1098-RU,
content with the data they had gained.
Until the Foundation gains more information
about SCP-1098 and the mysterious entity inside,
sending more resources in will only result
in them meeting a gruesome demise.
Until then, they can only speculate about
the true nature of the entity known as the
Master of Puppets.
Now go check out “SCP-2696 Haunted Victorian
Mansion” and “SCP-4153 - Haunted House
Horror - It Came from Site-9!” for more
anomalous haunted houses from SCP Explained!